[Musique]
au royaume d'hawaï vivait une jeune
princesse elle été chéris et aimé par
son peuple son véritable nom était
victoria cailloux lane i call any new
eyes la palapa cavecchi huey luna l'îlot
on l'avait appelée victoria en l'honneur
de la reine d'angleterre et cailloux
l'ani qui signifie le sommet du paradis
la mère de cailloux l'ani était la soeur
du roi kalakaua son père était un
gentleman écossais
[Musique]
pendant que cayola ni grandissait sa
nation était florissante hawaï et est
admiré par le monde entier pour sa
beauté et pour son abondance
mais le petit paradis de cayola ni
n'allait pas toujours durer
alors qu'elle n'était encore qu'une
enfant sa mère tomba malade et mourut
le peuple hawaïen pleura beaucoup la
perte de sa souveraine et il pria pour
sa toute jeune fille
[Musique]
malgré son chagrin la princesse cailloux
l'ani allait rapidement découvrir la
mission qui serait la sienne gagné la
bataille pour l'avenir de l'archipel
hawaïen
[Musique]
maman
je vois encore dans ses yeux le chagrin
de la mort de sa mère c'est vrai mais
elle est très heureuse de voir votre
soeur vitesse donnée tant mieux ma soeur
du caractère c'est une bonne influence
pour calculer ni influence d'un père
l'est tout autant
même si dans mon cas cette main est
écossaise et non en moyenne ne vous en
faites pas ce soir un peuple fêtera
l'électrification de notre grande ville
et c'est leur princesse qui illuminera
ouailles on n'en fait pas trop quand
même
votre majesté gibson
[Musique]
évoquant les noyaux lourds à oman et au
canada
il y en a
dans comment obama est un homme
shawa
ah ok kikai
[Musique]
calmars et au local il est lavé aurait
donc oui tu as touché la française que
s'est il passé
il vous a touché il n'est rien fait mais
ira au nez et au pas et maiko loi arrêté
il n'a rien vu remettez-vous travail
nettoyer ça venait avec moi cailloux
l'ani et omar week-end
pour que je ne vous confonde pas
c'est magnifique vous ne tombez pas pour
une simple fait vraiment très élaboré on
n'a pas hésité à dépenser c'est l'argent
du contribuable dépenser comme si on
était l'ennemi nous devons trouver un
processus de médiation qui inclut les
besoins des autochtones à j'en suis
persuadé les intérêts de tous seront
pris en compte
ensuite on se retire et on laisse le
temps faire son oeuvre
si l'heure n'est pas légal et sept prix
très chers invités à votre santé et à
celle de ma nièce cailloux l'année
puisse-t-elle un jour devenir une grande
reine pour notre pays que cette
cérémonie de la lumière rappelle à tous
nos citoyens qu'elle est de sang royal a
un lit vahiné mesdames et messieurs à la
demande de sa majesté le roi kalakaua la
princesse k yulan y aura la chance
d'éclairer la ville d'honolulu pour la
toute première fois j'ai perdu le très
content tu ne t'en fais pas de là où
elle est cameri fière de toi nous
regarde a l'espoir de notre nation
[Applaudissements]
votre majesté
[Musique]
attendait le signal
non
votre altesse je vous prie
[Musique]
allons-y
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
protéger la prothèse veut dire qu'il
suffit il représente la voix d'hawaï et
citoyens que vous avez décidé d'ignorer
ces personnes demandent un nouveau
régime
il existe élection d'un nouveau conseil
et la démission des ministres kitson
leroy signera cette nouvelle
constitution nous prendrons le pouvoir
par la force
écoutez dans mon offre soeur stone il
n'y aura pas de sang versé ce soir vous
relâchez le ministre gibson et vous
pourrez vivre un peu plus longtemps
on fait quoi mais bien vous pas là c'est
toi mon frère soit relâché 13 pater
aller qu'avez vous faire sur stone et à
parfaire votre majesté on retrouve ses
côtés je dois vous et score qu'à mon
avis j'emmène maintenant je reste ici on
ne fait que possible de venir dans sa c4
island 3 dans la calèche je vais
t'éclater
entre trois et nous paraît aller plus
vite il faut pas rester là quad cochet
ya en avant
vous
[Musique]
paris un nouvel an
arrête ça
je descends tu l'as bien manger tout
doit prendre des forces la route est
longue jusqu'en angleterre
je vais quitter hawaï
je refuse de m'en aller
tu n'as pas ton mot à dire c'est pour ta
sécurité ça suffit arrête tes enfants
voyageront gens tu veux te noyer tu te
déteste cette toiture et de mourir pelle
tu n'as pas le droit de faire ça je suis
une princesse
mais je suis ton père et je refuse de te
mettre en danger
tu m'entends
c'est comme ceux qui me l'apprenez une
deuxième fois tu ne pourras pas être
heureux tant qu'il restera encore
quelque chose d'elle non ma chérie tu
sais bien que non et pourquoi suis-je
obligé de partir là je veux je veux
rester ici
non ma pompe et la mer sera toujours
dans ton coeur
[Applaudissements]
merci archie bienvenus je suis content
d'être arrivé théo viendra bus aller
voir bienvenue à vous avez l'air épuisé
j'ai besoin d'un ver rien qu'à vous
regardez bonjour elle est à couper le
souffle
vous avez grandi très vite votre altesse
cailloux l'année je n'ai pas l'intention
de rester cailloux manille ce ne sont
pas des princes
non clegg se prend souvent pour le roi
du monde
venez vous devez mourir de faim j'ai mis
une marmite de soupe sur le feu
cet idéal contre l'humidité et le froid
je vous promets que vous vous sentirez
chez vous on n'a rien de temps vous avez
une belle chambre avec vue sur le lagon
y'a pas à dire c'est vraiment une
princesse
j'ai cru comprendre que tout l'archipel
d'hawaï ta partie des textures et jeu
des plantations de sucre par ci par là
les thomson aussi ont des plantations
elle te plaît non pourquoi pas tu l'a
trompée elle se croit meilleur que nous
c'est une petite princesse venue du par
[Rires]
[Musique]
ans
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
celui ci est jolie
ce sont des coquillages ma mère et moi
on en ramasse et souvent sur la plage on
les appelle aulas des coquillages holla
holla ça veut dire la vie 1 un voyant
des coquillages de vie
les collectionne et on y laisse nos
souvenirs pour ne pas oublier
chacun d'entre eux à un souvenir datant
[Musique]
celui-ci c'est une journée que j'ai
passés devant l'océan avec ma mère et ma
tante lydien
certains ne sont pas très joli
celui-ci c'est pourquoi
[Musique]
la mort de ma mère
et cela alors
ceux là n'ont pas encore de souvenirs
il représente mon avenir
dis moi qu'est ce que ça fait d'être une
vraie princesse
[Musique]
caillou la vie
je m'en vais je parle
[Musique]
tu ne viens pas me dire au revoir
on vous appellera par votre nom anglais
musique les gones on m'a dit que vous
êtes habitué à certains certains
avantages princier dans votre pays natal
vous ne les aurais pas ici nous feront
de vous une jeune femme respectable loin
des pratiques barbares qu'on vous a
inculqué sarlat ici les étudiants ne
participe à toutes les tâches ménagères
tels que la lessive
vous ferez montlivault vidre également
mon pot de chambre me suis bien fait
comprendre parfaitement la réponse
adéquate et oui j'ai compris mes barnes
oui madame
peu importe que vous soyez princesse ou
roturière il n'y a aucune distinction
ici la directrice vous demande mais ce
mardi c'est très bizarre ayant
l'habitude de courrier c'est la part de
l'ailé watts
je veux faire la lessive en attendant
[Musique]
et qui relie merano évoquant la marque
mais chronolia aka komara moscou
quelques couennes cruciaux les cas lors
accueil à om mokona l'onac ou à la
loyola à olimar à al ahly pauline orient
robert chorale hélène à kookaï héroïque
la parole et qui comptera navarro
america la coop ou ali quoi royal
kalakaua époux lima au l'île au canot
valley nikiya manava calque ikaika nos
coûts mais qui connut cannavaro à bahia
qui couvrent prologue à la ruine à
l'époque où elle écoule en haïti au
marquage qui a et et à wana où il
travaille
la karma online à airolo lee qui a en a
poulet aux ics au boycot canaux meilleur
marconnet à louis royaume uni away cocoa
à calais loi qu'est ce que c'est
relavant c'est une lettre d'amour qui
lui écrire une lettre de toi que tu
viens tu viens dire l'ordre s'il te
plaît rôle à moi à moi
sale négresse mesdemoiselles
elle m'a attaqué la première non c'était
trop dur elle va affoler mal à la gorge
donnez moi ça
vous pouvez ramasser les morceaux votre
altesse
[Musique]
oui
on
à
m
[Musique]
devrait pas demain
kleib est ce que tu vas en vie en effet
pourrais tu m'apportes et des journaux
je pourrais est là tu me les apportera
oui tu peut m'accompagner
je ne suis pas en tenue
tu te prends pour un dandy pas vrai un
charmeur tu es bien sûr de toi
salim est dit que tu ne sais pas
embrassés tu as donc toi tu ne sais pas
mentir
salim et ne veux même pas parler la
victoire alors encore moins dire des
ragots à une enfant tel qu'à toi je ne
suis pas une enfant parce que ça va
tu aurais pu te faire mal petit gandhi
[Musique]
oh
e
non
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique]
on
e
à victoria alice me dit que vous êtes
très doué à l'école
quoi qui est il j'ai reçu des nouvelles
de votre père votre oncle le roi est
décédé
[Musique]
je vous présente toutes mes condoléances
il semblerait qu'il était malade depuis
longtemps mais ça a empiré il faut que
alice m'attend je donne a rejoint
victoria c'est votre tante qui sera
reine d'avoir ya présent et vous sent
mal
[Musique]
ma très chère cailloux la nuit c'était
le souhait de ton oncle et mon devoir de
te nommer héritière du trône
en attendant ce jour ma chérie il me
faut prendre soin de mon peuple est
oublié mon chagrin n'oublie pas cailloux
la nuit tu dois toujours avoir une place
dans ton coeur pour les vivants
[Musique]
il préfère rester seul
mon père dit que tu va nous quitter
je voudrais que tu restes et
l'importance de toutes façons tu pars à
l'université c'est important très
important
tu ne te rends pas compte de l'enfer que
je subis de vivre avec toi de te voir
tous les jours de voir ton sourire tout
rires sentir ton parfum en fait oui et
je sais que ce n'est pas le bon moment
situation va partir et je t'aime
cailloux l'année je me désespère d'amour
pour toi
[Musique]
tu te désespère clair
chez m'impatiente mais je me meurs
d'amour pour toi
je me dois
[Musique]
je vous parle de la légitimité de la
constitution votre la constitution a été
signé par le roi je ne reconnais pas une
constitution qui est injuste envers le
peuple
écrite par des voleurs des voleurs vous
dit sinon ce thornton vous êtes parvenus
à faire plier mon frère sachez que moi
je ne serais pas aussi souple
nous agissons dans l'intérêt du peuple
votre majesté le peuple tout à fait
cette nouvelle constitution a été
reconnue par les citoyens de notre pays
par le peuple
monsieur sort stone c'est cette
constitution là qu'il réclame et moi
aussi qu'elle soit signé et appliqué
immédiatement comme vous voudrez
votre majesté je crains que vous pouvez
disposer monsieur dole
[Musique]
st
envoie ce message de la part du ministre
steven sport donnant lui les vies et des
biens américains sont en danger
[Rires]
gbc le guidon pour que tu puisse monter
mais c'est en vélo
vas-y essai allez tu vois ma cheville
assieds toi celle là
[Musique]
ça fait un peu mal j'ai entendu dire que
la cheville est l'endroit le plus
sensible chez une femme
[Musique]
hawaï endroit le plus sensible chez les
femmes
cette trouvaille art hudon
[Musique]
il
mais si je te demande de me poser je
n'en sais rien il faut que tu demandes
[Musique]
le voudrait-il ce n'est pas très
romantique
[Musique]
victoria
qu'avec you île où d'un vélo kalani
noailles la pala bakoyannis veux tu
m'épouser
[Musique]
si je devais repartir pour hawaii que
ferais-tu
je te suivrai
c'est vrai ouais ouais
[Musique]
tu nerveux à cause de tous ces gens
n'est ce pas tu n'as rien à craindre
il n'y aura pas plus belle que toi
pendant la fête c'est certain ton
premier baiser avec live il est dans
quelques pièges
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
vous êtes ravissante comme à chaque fois
ils disaient mais j'habitais je revois
cette réception très réussi un autre
voyage je veux que vous me donniez tous
les détails ce soir elle est à moitié
polynésienne l'autre moitié d'edimbourg
et crève à une relation romantique avec
cette créature est ce que vous les
trouvez attirante elle a un certain
charme de tigresse de la jungle salue la
victoria laisse moi te présenter le
double de winchester et sa nouvelle
femme la duchesse nouvelles il y en a
une autre
nous admirions votre beauté de l'autre
bout de la pièce
savez vous lire et écrire
couramment en hawaïen et en anglais
david hawaï est le pays le plus
alphabétisées du monde votre robe est
splendide
vous pourriez presque passer pour une
noble comme nous la lignée royale de la
princesse remonte à plus de 1500 ans
depuis quand avez-vous votre titre
elisabeth un mois à tout à l'heure je
suis ravie de faire votre connaissance
je suis profondément désolé lisabeth
l'honnêteté a toujours été un défaut
chez mon frère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
excuse moi ça m'a blessé n'y pense pas
ce sont des idiots qui se pavanent
j'en ai rien à faire de ce qu'il croit
tant mieux rien du tout d'accord
c'est seulement que ça m'ennuie de
rester assis cela comme un meuble
le même statut
[Musique]
des nouvelles
oui de la part de calais oit
tu veux rentrer dans ton pays
[Musique]
ac l'ail puis je te dire un mot en privé
ainsi vous permettez victoire je t'aime
merci beaucoup
si c'est à propos du duc et de la
duchesse vitoria jeu les demander en
mariage oui et elle a accepté
tant mieux c'est ce que nous pensions si
tu veux qu'elle reste ici et si tu veux
l'épouser elle ne doit jamais voir ceci
régis suivez-moi
[Musique]
nous
léon jouhaux compris oiseaux noté
souvenez vous à washington a approuvé
cela bien sûr la démocratie est
américaine prenez le ballet sortez les
employés laissez-nous passer compris
recul et alma tapas stade où il va
mademoiselle madame connelly est là la
couturière
10 pence c'est madame maintenant depuis
peu je cherche du travail s'il vous
plaît des serviettes dans quel sens
vraiment mais elle a toujours été une
belle alice
votre manteau et trompait mêmes
conneries puis-je
pierre prenez-le
[Musique]
e
je me demande seulement s'il est l'homme
qu'il te faut vu les circonstances si tu
peux me dire qu'il est à prendre pour
époux je suis toujours ton père que je
sache j'ai perdu ce privilège il ya deux
ans quand tu m'a abandonnée au fait
pourquoi est ce que tu es la nature dont
lui aucun de mes telle erreur de caisse
télégramme par le tuer
reste là où sont-ils où les avez vous
cachez monarchie renversée arrestation
prévenez la princesse pourquoi pourquoi
victoria
vous allez vous marier tu étais au
courant pour ça tu étais au courant oui
je le savais alors je ne suis rien pour
toi tu réponds moi ce n'est pas ça je
voulais attendre jusqu'à notre mariage
était supposé de suivre sans broncher
c'est ça non mais je t'aime
c'est ce que tu dis
8 orior il n'y a jamais eu de victoria
il n'y en aura jamais
[Musique]
beyou l'a ni yulan y attend j'ai fait
une erreur je suis désolé tu as tu me
suivrait avoir hissé le fallait je
maintiens que je le ferai s'il faut en
arriver là oui aurait toi tu crois que
plus important de ma vie
eh bien pas du tout peut-être trop
[Musique]
m
quelle manie
j'ai eu des paroles peu aimables avec
théo hier soir pourquoi at il fait ça il
doit avoir ses propres intérêts à
protéger
il est fort attristé par la façon dont
les choses ont tourné entre toi ils sont
fils c'est sa faute que ce soit ou non
le meilleur moment
il est amoureux de toi mais il est parti
alors son amour à peu d'intérêt
dis moi comment nous avons perdu à hawaï
[Musique]
te souviens-tu du garde du corps de ton
oncle oui c'est lui qui a organisé une
rébellion
candau les soeurs stone non renverser le
gouvernement
son plan était de marcher sur nos lulu
et forcer le régime de faure stone à se
dissoudre
mais ces hommes n'étaient pas préparés à
ce qui les attendait a été un massacre
prémédité j'en ai peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez témoins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien soir au cou trop
[Musique]
et tant que les biens pâles a été
envahie par des valeurs et des filles de
joie
elle a été arrêtée on l'a déclaré
coupable de trahison et condamnés à une
réclusion à domicile à perpétuité et
tous ses biens ont été saisis
[Musique]
et les genoux
je n'ai eu de nouvelles d'aucun des deux
[Musique]
nous pourrions faire une demande auprès
du président américain pour qu'il nous
donne son soutien même si on trouvait le
moyen de le voir le président cleveland
a bientôt terminé son mandat
alors il faut agir vite
tu crois que je ne saurais pas persuadé
un président laurence la tuer la digne
fille de ta mère
[Musique]
je
donc j'ai battu osiek
[Musique]
tu aurais pu le suivre
je devais être trop fier trop fier je
vois la fierté peut empêcher d'accomplir
bien des choses
dis moi avoue tu veux tu dire ceci s'il
te plaît qu'est ce que c'est théo lairis
pour toi sa façon de demander pardon je
suppose la presse américaine attendra au
port il sert que je viens au sawi thirst
en scène est assurée il a publié un
bulletin des plus enflammées dans le
plus grand journal de new york
pourquoi ne suis-je pas surprise ces
textes a besoin de correction
pourquoi ne suis-je pas surpris c'est
penser qu'elle viendra pieds nus plus
que probable effet
on dit ici mademoiselle mesdames et
messieurs mesdames et messieurs merci
d'être venus jusqu'ici je voudrais vous
présenter ma fille la princesse cailloux
l'ani de hawaii à la voix la fiq
je viens vous voir 5 vous m'ayez invités
et m'adresser à vous plus fort s'il vous
plaît je n'ai pas d'autres pouvoirs
qu'on de vous dire ce que j'ai dans le
coeur plus fort petit vous parler notre
langue
on prépare les plus forts mademoiselle
article a dit que trois représentants
américains à gotein sur mes terres on
demandait à votre grand pays de me
confisquer mon royaume sans jamais
m'avoir consulté
ils s'en sont emparés comme des malotrus
de quoi est-ce que vous parlez vous
comprends pas c'est une galinon plus
supportable
il y à 70 ans
de nombreux chrétiens d'amérique sont
venus avec leur famille pour évangéliser
hawaï aujourd'hui trois des enfants de
ces missionnaires en appel à votre
gouvernement pour détruire l'oeuvre de
leurs parents moi je suis jeune sans
expérience et seul pas un membre de mon
peuple pour m'accompagner
alors que j'ai en face de moi tous ces
politiciens mais je choisi de prendre la
parole pour défendre les droits de mon
peuple et je les entends j'entends leurs
pleurs dans mon coeur et c'est leur
plainte qui me donne la force et le
courage
je suis aussi plus forte grâce à ma foi
en dieu je suis forte car je sais que ma
cause est juste
je suis forte et j'aurai la force des 70
millions d habitants de ce pays de
liberté qu'ils entendront mon appel et
refuseront de laisser leurs drapeaux se
tâcher de déshonneur
[Musique]
merci y at il des questions oui oui moi
par ici oui et monsieur vie ici
princesse kyle amis allez vous
rencontrer le président je demeure aux
états unis en tant que simples visiteurs
et je n'ai aucune invitation à la maison
blanche
mais si vous voulez bien m'aider
j'espère changer cela vous pourriez me
rendre visite de façon informelle
non quelle idée jamais une dame ne se
rend au domicile d'un gentleman sans y
avoir été formellement invité et je ne
pense pas que la stature publique du
président cleveland façon quelconque
différence combien de temps attendre et
vous pour une invitation aussi longtemps
qu'il faudra
et s'il décide de ne pas vous voir du
tout je profiterai longtemps de votre
hospitalité
ce sera tout pour cet après-midi
mesdames et messieurs merci beaucoup à
vous tous merci
son accent nous dit nombre sa silhouette
évoque new york et son choeur clame
hawaï pas du tout ce à quoi je
m'attendais elle est loin de là et me
semi demi barbares qu'on nous avait
promis
christian on voit ça à l'imprimerie
immédiatement et le gros titre la
princesse se prend pour une reine je
suis venu en amérique pour voir le
président je ne veux pas d'un déjeuner
avec la first lady
mais tu n'es pas une politicienne alors
je dois me contenter d'un simple
déjeuner oui oui sous couvert d'un
simple déjeuner nous pouvons rencontrer
l'homme le plus influent d'amérique du
doit marcher sur des oeufs cailloux
l'ani
votre prénom est tellement jolie tout
comme vous ma chère vous êtes beaucoup
plus belle en vrai que dans le journal
merci beaucoup
grover a tout fait pour se joindre à
nous aujourd'hui quand on parle du loup
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance ma réunion a
été annulée
je suis contente déjeuner avec ont mangé
il est toujours là je savais que pour
être libérés vous désirez quelque chose
madame du cumin merci votre altesse il
est impossible d'ignorer votre présence
ici
les médias sont en admiration devant
vous certains sénateurs ont moins
d'influencé sur la presse que vous
semblez en avoir son altesse comprend
bien qu'elle n'est pas là à titre
officiel monsieur le président merci ce
que mon père veut dire c'est que je suis
ravi d'être votre invité et je ne me
permettrais pas de parler de la
politique d'hawaï
d'ailleurs cela me fait penser à cette
volaille la volaille vous fait penser à
one oui d'une certaine façon
naturel immaculé parfaite
depuis la nuit des temps elle a toujours
été la même et le poivre est demeuré les
pistes parfaite pour elle la volée mais
dernièrement le sel un minéral blancs
venus de la mer est devenue à la mode
veillez à nant ajouté qu'un petit peu
houle équilibre parfait pourrait bien en
être atterré
et si vous introduisez une épice venus
d'amérique tel que le cumin par exemple
le goût du sel devient trop fort et le
plat est raté
mais c'est le président si vous
permettez
c'est très mauvais dites moi comment
peut-on restaurer sa saveur naturelle le
cumin n'a pas sa place sur la volaille
et bien princesse je n'ai plus que
quatre semaines à ce poste mais je
promets de faire de mon mieux et de
réduire l'utilisation du cumin mais
mettez de l'ordre dans vos épices
rapidement mademoiselle le président-élu
maquille l'est de l'ohio et d'après ce
que j'en ai vu
il n'est pas très doué en cuisine
messieurs elle a peut être réussi à
gagner la confiance de cleveland
mais le nouveau président un avis tout
d'autres
mckinley c'est écouter les riches de ce
pays
il sait que nous y sommes utiles il
comprend également que quiconque possède
d'hawaï contrôler le pacifique
donc la princesse a échoué ce qu'elle a
fait est un acte de trahison
allons-nous le tolérer non hors de
question si jamais elle revenait je vote
pour qu'elle soit immédiatement mis aux
arrêts que quand ils vont accomplir
ainsi elle ne vous est plus d'aucune
utilité les états unis vous suivent nous
suivent
ce n'est pas ce que vous vouliez dire si
si évidemment ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'en prisonniers la princesse ne
ferait que créer davantage de tensions
entre les deux camps c'est inutile mais
il n'y a qu'un seul quand sonne forte
notre camp
c'est étonnant que vous ne l'ayez pas
encore compris
[Musique]
il est arrivé
merci
[Musique]
j'ai pas ordre de vous escorté à la
résidence de la reine votre altesse
suivez-moi
[Musique]
caillou là ni mon enfant comme tu as
grandi c'est fou tu es devenue une vraie
femme tu aimes magnifique ton pays tu
attends depuis longtemps te revoir en
femme remplit de joie
que s'est il passé
les etats unis soutiennent les anti
royalistes il est très clair aujourd'hui
que ça a toujours été leur attention
nous sommes en train d'être annexée on
nous retire notre souveraineté
les kanaks à ont signé une pétition qui
a été ignorée pour nous a fait taire je
suis tellement désolée
[Musique]
c'est une action très noble que tu as
fait mon enfant malheureusement tu es
revenu à l'heure la plus triste de notre
pays
cérémonie d'annexion aura lieu demain
je refuse d'y assister à la place je
donnerai ma propre fait une sorte
enterrement pour notre pays une femme a
visé un jour m'a dit
qu'il faut toujours une place dans son
coeur pour les vivants c'est ce que je
ferai
[Musique]
ma chère cailloux l'ani je voudrais que
tu comprennes les raisons qui m'ont
poussé à tout quitter
je pense qu'il sera plus facile pour toi
de partir sans moi j'ai agi sans
réfléchir et je m'en excuse du fond du
coeur mais s'il te plait je t'en supplie
ne nous oublie pas notre amour mérite
d'être éternel je prie pour que nous
nous retrouvions un jour
[Musique]
soit toujours courageuse princesse bien
aimé personne ne peut te résister et
certainement pas moi donc live qui
t'aime
la nuit où le pays a disparu
jurés vous allégeance à dieu et à votre
pays je le jure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
str
il me voit qu'aux quelques années 80
où as tu trouvais ça
o'callaghan hayes flannery o'connor
kawano konoha paulino à la map pillay
puis je vous dire un mot votre altesse
merci de me recevoir votre altesse
je ne peux qu'imaginer les émotions que
vous devez ressentir aujourd'hui
maintenant kawaii est un territoire
américain
il faut faire de nouvelles lois à cet
effet trois commissaires d'état vont
venir aujourd'hui pour ma 6t lorinser
stone et moi même nous demandions si
vous pourriez si vous pouviez accepté de
tenir un dîner en l'honneur de ses
commissaires d'état oui je sais votre
altesse ses commissaires vont poser les
jalons sur lesquels reposera l'avenir
d'hawaï et leur connaissance du pays se
limite à ce que thornton leur a dit
soyez une bonne hôtesse montrez-leur
notre solidarité c'est une très
importante soirée pour n'en est sans
doute pour vous également
bonsoir tristesse notre pays
mes hommages votre altesse bonsoir
lourde et zain presque service à vos
citoyens princesse bonsoir je l'espère
de certaines autres altesse monsieur
bonsoir monsieur
encore un peu de sable
mesdames et messieurs mesdemoiselles
permettez moi de vous dire à quel point
je suis ravi de vous voir tous vous
amuser n'hésitez pas à goûter le paye
c'est tout à fait délicieux on m'a donné
l'insigne honneur de présenter notre
notre prestigieuse hôtesses la charmante
princesse cailloux la nier
merci j'ai grand espoir que tout le
monde a apprécié les spécialités locales
qui vous ont été servis évidemment la
glisse n'est pas un moyen
c'était plutôt un piège tendu à mon très
cher père pour qu'il n'approche pas trop
des coups à wye est sur le point
d'entrer dans le xxème siècle et sans
trouver une nation changé c'est pourquoi
ce soir je vous offre que nous
embarquions sur cette transition en tant
qu'ami monsieur soeur stone et monsieur
dole souhaitait un gouvernement
populaire fort bien il est arrivé sous
saut de la constitution des états unis
d'amérique
qu'est ce que cela peut vouloir dire si
vous demandez à monsieur soeur stone il
vous répondra que si vous possédez des
terres vous avez le droit de vote
quelle coïncidence les autochtones ont
aucune terre si vous demandez à l'un des
commissaires venus de washington tous
présents ici ce soir ils vous diront
avec une fierté immense que chaque
citoyen américain masculin qui sait lire
ou écrire a le droit de vous du citoyen
anglo américain bien sûr quant aux
autres un jour eux aussi ions prêt à
gouverner et je suis impatient d'y être
mais une forte rythme en ce jour n'est
pas arrivé au non au contraire vous vous
apercevrez que les kanaks à ont très
envie d'avoir leur mot à dire dans cette
nouvelle gouvernance
mrg horn où voulez vous en venir
exactement je veux en venir à parler du
droit de vote
je lance une pétition pour donner le
suffrage universel à tout le peuple
je vous demande pardon sénateurs nous ne
pouvons pas tout bonnement considérer la
pétition d'une aristocrate des chevaux
votre respect notre gouvernement ne vous
reconnaît pas comme politicienne
légitime qui présentera votre pétition
moi je le ferai
votre majesté votre altesse mesdames et
messieurs je propose formellement une
révision au traité d'annexion de ce pays
ce n'est vraiment ni l'heure ni
l'endroit de parler de sa passion folle
dingue et tous les commissaires d'état
sont là je trouve le moment tout à fait
opportun puis-je puis je vous rappeler
que cette jeune femme n'est plus une
princesse sans vous manqués tri
tout ça est absurde franchement son ford
avez-vous complètement perdu la tête
nos familles ont cultivé axter nos
familles
et aujourd'hui vous tout seul vous
proposez de détruire leur travail la
présence du gouvernement des états-unis
danser il doit être dans l'intérêt de la
totalité de son père absolue miss
périgord
de combien d'autochtones parlons nous
exactement 90% de toute la population
je pense que nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix que de présenter la pétition de
miss cleghorn devant le congrès
bien ce qui a débuté comme un charmant
dîner s'est transformé en folie
politique
j'ai bon espoir que demain avoue
recouvrit y est votre raison pour
l'instant je vous souhaite une
week end mois a poussé le fauteuil de ta
mère on s'en va rester
je vous en prie rester avec nous
[Musique]
bonne soirée
qu'il parte laissez-le
[Musique]
vous comprendrez vite ce que je veux
dire ce sont des conditions parfaites
mais qui type de faune et de flore c'est
merveilleux et la brise fraîche qui on
vient de l'océan à l'automne et très
appel
[Musique]
tu te souviens être venu sur cette île
quand tu étais petit les couleurs de
l'océan
c'est comme un kaléidoscope de lumière
chaque fois
tu étais même parti à la pêche tout nu
puis tu essayé d'attraper des poissons à
la main
[Musique]
m
à la mairie
[Musique]
mais pour nos boules à la rigueur
non
hayao et qu'elle est alors parce qu'il
vient de se passer de la cour n'est pas
un endroit reculé
bien continue en continuant
paris 6 mai sur les commissaires
mesdames
caillaud la nique
non
c'est avec un grand plaisir que je vous
écris cette lettre les efforts constants
de la princesse pour mettre fin aux
ressentiments hawaï et son acceptation
du nouvel ordre établi ont été fort
apprécié par notre communauté
par conséquent de nouveaux territoires
d'hawaï acceptent d'accorder à tous les
hawaiiens tous les droits de la
citoyenneté
[Musique]
mais kanaker ont le droit de voter oui
tu as réussi ma chérie
la règle
n'êtes vous pas le dandy prétentieux que
j'ai un jour poussé dans un fossé
j'étais toujours dit que je te suivrai
hawaï pourquoi n'est-il pas venu plus
tôt les circonstances n'étaient pas
idéales
bon
mon père est décédé
toutes mes condoléances
il m'a laissé tout ses intérêts hawaï un
héritage
pour ça que tu es là non
tu étais magnifique qui tout à l'heure
est-ce que tu as lu mes lettres
oui je les ai lus
[Musique]
pour
je n'ai jamais cessé de penser à toi
j'étais un idiot sans cervelle j'ai été
égoïste
[Musique]
je t'aime qu'ayew l'année
j'étais aussi
[Musique]
tu as toujours été dans mon cas
et s'ils repartent et en angleterre on
se marierait là bas
pourquoi repartirait en angleterre mutu
tu ne peux pas me demander qui est la
nuit j'ai des obligations
j'en ai aussi dit c'est ici
[Musique]
non tu n'en as plus
ton pays est en train de s'effondrer tu
veux vraiment rester ici le voir
disparaître tant que je resterai là il
ne disparaîtra pas
tant que je resterai là moi non plus je
ne disparaîtrait pas
[Musique]
je
tu es vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
la tuque life
je crois que la transition n'a pas été
très violente pour une fois
je crois
que cette fois ci une nation toute
entière a disparu monsieur paul
non votre altesse elle vit encore
[Musique]
lv en faut
les hawaiiens se souviennent avec
émotion de la princesse cailloux l'ani
et de la fierté qu'elle a rendue à son
peuple
la flamme de notre grande princesse
brune ardemment dans l'âme de notre pays
[Musique]
à
e
la princesse kaye all and i est morte le
6 mars 1899 à l'âge de 23 ans
moins d'un an après l'annexion de hawaii
par les états unis
beaucoup pensent qu'elle est morte de
chagrin après avoir perdu son pays
[Musique]